me llamo lilitos kaya soy diseñadora de
moda
estoy en parís y les pido que apoyen a
ucrania
paren la guerra deben saber que esta
guerra es un asunto de todos
ucrania protege al mundo en este momento
deben saberlo
gracias en qué
[Música]
gracias a la ayuda de la federación de
alta costura de la moda ability kafka ya
pudo irse de kiev con su hija pero sin
su colección por solidaridad pública en
los muros de los códigos de barras
relacionados con el trabajo de sus
amigas diseñadoras ucranianas y el ipca
pesca ya debía desfilar en parís para
presentar su tarjeta a portada del
próximo invierno pero la guerra lo
impidió
la guerra está en todas las mentes cómo
hablar entonces de moda afrontando la
paradoja porque hoy la ropa es accesoria
lo que predomina es el mensaje de navas
al ya ya había imaginado esta
escenografía para valencianas de seis
meses presentar su colección en un
universo hostil las modelos luchan
contra las borrascas de nieve arrastran
bolsas de basura de navas al ya vivió
esta experiencia huyó de su georgia
natal en 1993 durante la guerra civil
apoyada por el kremlin
periodistas clientes compradores están
instalados cómodamente detrás de un
cristal como símbolo de una protección
ilusoria
creo que hay tantos problemas de tipo
político en el mundo hoy en día
creo que a veces como diseñadora uno se
pregunta mismos que estamos en para qué
servimos de arte de expresión es
importante entender justamente la
libertad de expresión
y lo que podemos comunicar a través de
nuestro arte es importante y mantener el
coraje de seguir transformando el mundo
de mañana así no sea fáciles
marín se decidió revelar el proceso de
sus diseños concebidos a partir de
productos reciclados re usados porque le
interesa más el modo de vida que la moda
lo que trate de hacer en el piso en el
que nos encontramos es más allá de la
moda
entender la ropa
retomar el tiempo de entender lo que
toma ser un vestido quién está detrás de
un vestido y por lo tanto poner a los
artesanos y a todo mi equipo de este
piso en el lugar de las obras de arte
pero la obra es la clasificación la
selección sobre lo que estamos sentados
aquí
transformar las cosas que existen que
hacen parte del mundo en el que vivimos
así no siempre sea color de rosa
y cómo transformar para hacer algo útil
porque es para vestir pero también que
nos corresponda y que corresponda a
nuestros valores en nosotros mismos
preservar la creación para garantizar la
libertad de expresión pero sin olvidar
salvaguardar el medio ambiente fueron
numerosos los diseñadores de esta
temporada los que enaltecieron los
méritos del reciclaje para su joven
marca train antón recuperó el as de
kitesurf pero no sólo eso el reciclaje
es algo que siempre hemos hecho en add
line antes usábamos fibras plásticas
recicladas para crear nuevas materias
desarrollamos generaciones de jerseys de
manera exclusiva para la marca y digamos
que el reciclaje no se veía
en esta temporada tenía ganas de
arqueología del taller de la crisis la
turbio
y tener muchos recursos con los que
encontramos y llevar el taller al
espacio del desfile
fue eso evidentemente el vestido con
cápsulas de café
es lo que simboliza finalmente lo que
más representa esta idea
militar retirado benjamín memorial se
preparó en londres en central saint
martins en el 2013
yo salía del ejército era paracaidista
mi concepto inicial era reencontrar mi
ingenuidad perdida durante mi servicio
militar a través de las cintas
magnéticas de casete porque ello
simbolizaba mi infancia
y entonces reconstruir eso era como una
recuperación de mi inocencia
esta es una chaqueta tejida con cintas
magnéticas de cassette
todas las partes cafés son cintas de
audio y las partes de color son algodón
out en serio depende de lo que tengamos
en función de las temporadas son piezas
icónicas de la marca porque con ella nos
dimos a conocer que bin hammam y él
también proviene de la central saint
martins de londres ha vestido a lady
gaga taylor swift o björk porque el
reciclaje el glamour combina bien
normalmente hago moda con humor a la
gente debe darle gusto
los visto como aliens porque juego
muchos videojuegos
todos los dementes de hecho son viejos
inventarios de banco que se cree que las
ubicaciones las agua aleatoriamente pero
ese es en realidad es para esconder
manchas que hainán lenin guay rotos este
tipo de cosas eso este débil es un buen
ejemplo
todas las marcas grandes y pequeñas
decidieron apoyar a ucrania con
donaciones por el fin de ayudar al alto
comisariado de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados